hey youtubers it's Charlie so this is
gonna be my flash of two worlds video
there's a whole bunch of stuff to
explain so as I get through top moments
I'll try to explain the multiverse what
the TV show is doing with that and some
of the new characters really like the
whole purpose of this episode is just to
put Jay Garrick on Team flash and
establish him as a mentor for Barry this
season in real quick reminder new round
of the giveaway starts now I'm giving
away a reverse flash ring all you have
to do to enter is be a subscriber and
leave a comment on this video so just
careful for spoilers from the episode if
you haven't seen it yet I know some of
you were watching and it got preempted
by baseball or something so you might've
had to go back and watch that the first
7 minutes but here we go number 5 Jay
Garrick explains zoom what he said is is
that zoom first showed up about the same
time he got his powers on earth 2 which
was about two years ago so he's really
only been the flash about a year longer
than Barry has been the flash and he
lost his powers the minute the wormhole
opened and sucked him in so he didn't
say zoom stole his speed he just says he
doesn't know how he lost it zoom was
trying to kill him he wants to be the
only flash on any world so it sounds
like zoom is just crossing over into
other universes trying to kill all the
Flash's they weren't really clear that
zoom was from earth 2 so he could be
from a different earth but he's
basically just working his way all over
the multiverse trying to kill the other
flashes Jay said that zoom wants to be
the best so just remember that I think
the language that they wrote in there is
actually gonna be important to figuring
out who zoom is eventually zoom has that
line in the comic-con trailer where he
said heroes die so he doesn't want to be
a hero he just wants to be the best
hunter number 4 meet zoom voiced by Tony
Todd we finally get to see him full-on
and we get to hear the voice I mean we
heard it in the trailer Connor but but
this time it was just a much more
palanca scene this here is what it looks
like when someone crosses between
Earth's there's still a whole lot we
don't know about jumping back and forth
between earth 1 and earth 2 maybe just
the flashes can do it maybe it has
something to do with being at these
specific pockets of energy for now I'm
just gonna assume that the only people
that you can go back and forth are zoom
and Barry just because they have Speed
Force powers Martin Stein filling in
with Cisco is slowly figuring things out
and then they're both slowly kind of
going crazy
in slightly different ways so under
number three Martin Stein figures out
what's going on with Cisco the line the
Cisco had was again a vibe then I see a
vision of something that's happened and
then it goes away but all the visions
have been to people that are from
earth-2 so he's just sensing the
alternate reality like the alternate
energy that's being given off by these
people I was actually a little surprised
that Cisco's reaction the fact that he
didn't want to tell people but the
reason he explains is because Harrison
wells made it seem like he was really
special he told you know you have this
great destiny ahead of you and he turned
out to be super evil so Cisco's getting
a very sinister quote-unquote vibe from
his abilities he just he doesn't trust
it at all so he doesn't want to tell
everyone because he's not sure how to
deal with it yet do not be surprised if
the same thing happens with Caitlin snow
hopefully it will be the exact same
thing because she also has metahuman
abilities the show just hasn't explored
that yet if we've learned anything from
genre shows it's that when a character
gets a special ability and hides it from
all of his friends it never ends well on
the flip side to that Martin Stein looks
like he's slowly losing his mind and
there is a little bit of silly setup
like oh I'm never gonna be merging with
anyone else like he had a couple lines
of dialogue that made it seem like he
was never going to fuse his firestorm of
course we know that's totally not true
sometimes when you see setups like this
and you're like okay they're very
clearly setting this up for the twist
that surprise surprise he's gonna merge
with another firestorm
he gave the writers a little bit of a
pass just because they're writing that
for people that do not read comics on
the number two meet patty spivot newest
member of Joe's task force and probably
future member of Team flash does anybody
want to lay bets now on how long it's
gonna take her to figure out that
Barry's the flash I've been seeing like
two or three episodes maybe faster than
that maybe it'll take longer I mean I
mean we'll see most of her storyline and
most of our interaction with Barry is
gonna take place at the police station
when he is not the flash I feel like
both Jay and Patty had great
introductions this season like the setup
for their character was really well
thought out like they're not just out
for revenge
they have tragedy in their past that
they're trying to work past they're
trying to move forward which was kind of
a theme of the first episode they're
highly skilled they want to help people
they're not like completely shackled by
their emotions so I'll be really happy
that Patty isn't going to be like drag
getting her baggage around all season
long but it is interesting to know that
weather wizard at least on the TV show
killed her father before he got his
powers when he was just a normal bank
robber it was after he and his brother
got superpowers that patty was like this
is terrible evil people are getting
superpowers and no one will be able to
stop them from hurting everyone I need
to do something about this so that was
her big call-to-action
the other big thing that's gonna be
happening with her character on the show
is that she's being brought in as a
potential love interest for Barry's
character like that that was part of her
character description when they cast her
so if you read into some of the dialogue
that she has about kismet in faith then
you know that's kind of the direction
that's headed but that also kind of
speaks to her comic book history as a
speedster she got speed force powers on
two different occasions one like way way
back in the comics when she first
debuted she became what was known as
Miss Flash then she really didn't show
up a whole lot until Geoff Johns brought
her back during his wallet West run and
she became like like a person at the
police station during that run instead
of being just a regular police officer
or a detective like she's gonna be on
the show she was a forensic scientist
just like Barry then during the new 52
they they put her and Barry in this like
ongoing relationship in that version of
events he wasn't going out with Iris he
wasn't married to her anything like that
so there been a number of different
versions of her character but the
producers brought her in this season
who's just gonna be able to match that
Barry level of energy that really
excitable nerd energy that he has
speaking of which when they're nerding
out here together watching the
interrogation they were talking about
monty python's holy grail that was the
reference she was talking about the
troll in the bridge but of course moving
on to my number one meet Jay Garrick the
Crimson comet so really important here
there been a couple changes to Jay
Garrick from the comics you can see
right away already
he made this big deal about how he used
to be a scientist part-time scientist
part-time superhero but I guess I guess
the super part isn't around anymore
really you can see this coming a mile
away they're just they're trying to
build chemistry between those two
characters they both lost a really
important part of themselves they're
gonna bond over that and help each other
heal Jay lost his speed Caitlin lost
Ronnie so they're both gonna rebuild
their shattered emotions together I'm
not really expecting anything crazy out
of that relationship and remember it's
been six months since Ronnie's died so
she is slowly going to be rebuilding
her life throughout the rest of the
season but for the most part Jay
Garrick's job at STAR Labs of Earth -
from from his world is pretty similar to
what Caitlin does at STAR Labs on this
world so their relationship is kind of a
mirror of what's going on with Patty and
Barry it's just that
Patty does not know that Barry is the
flash yet I say you know giant yet it
was a little confusing early on why
Barry was trying to shut him down when
they when they first met you know he
just he wouldn't believe anything he
said the big speech with iris just
explained that he just doesn't want to
trust anyone anymore that's like you
know Batman mode I'm not even gonna
trust my friends so again iris has to be
the voice of reason telling him you know
your friends believe in you you need to
believe in them or else they're all
gonna bolt the whole reason they did
this is because they want to let you
know that Jay Garrick is not an evil
character he is exactly who he says he
is he's not gonna turn into another wolf
in the henhouse like Harrison wells was
and just to explain that twist at the
end - Harrison wells that showed up at
the end that's on earth to earth -
Harrison wells will be a theme this
season Tom Cavanagh is still a series
regular let me know in the comments
though what was your favorite moment was
it Barry learning how to throw lightning
throw Speed Force lightning that's what
he was doing or was it just meeting the
new characters Jay Garrick and patty
spivot this episode probably gonna go
down as one of my favorites this season
I mean remember there's 23 total so
there's still a lot more left to come
and I almost forgot about the big twist
at the end
irises mother shows up so we'll find out
what went on between her and Joe and how
Wally West is going to fit into that
equation it was really like a knee-jerk
WTF at the end so we're gonna have to
wait till next week to really find out
what's going on with that to get some
actual scenes with them so hopefully
I've explained some of the new comic
book characters some of the new concepts
you know when they said there's 52
pockets of energy that doesn't mean
they're gonna be visiting 52 earths it
just means that there are 52 places in
Central City where there are breaches
really all that means is that you're
just gonna see metahumans from Earth to
start popping up all over Central City
there were some moments in the New York
Comic Con trailer that did not make it
into this episode so I'll post links for
that in the description so you can see
just there's a little bit extra stuff
but tomorrow is a new episode we're
gonna meet anarchy he's gonna be a
really big character in season 2 he'll
be like the small bad you have damian
darhk-- big bad anarchy gonna be the
small bad so why you guys wait for all
that stuff to post you can
click here for the New York Comic Con
flash arrow trailers Edge's I've jammed
them into one big video and you can
click here for this week's Gotham video
I just posted this a little while ago
thank you so much watching everybody
let's hop out I'll see you guys tomorrow